[MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIA TURSHEN: This is
super fun because, yes, I've
known Karen for 25 years.
We met in the third grade.
We did some math.
And so when "Small
Victories," which
was my first cookbook as
a solo author came out,
I was right here.
And it was pretty much
exactly two years ago.
And I feel like I recognize
some of you from that.
We made turkey meatballs,
and it was so fun.
And that was such
a joy, because that
was the first event I had
ever done for my own cookbook.
And now I'm in this very
unusual, very privileged
position of this is my
third book in three years.
So that was-- I feel
very full circle.
And thank you for coming.
I appreciate it.
So now and again--
we have lots of displays--
it's all about
menus and leftovers.
And it started
off as a book just
about reinventing leftovers,
because I love leftovers.
I think the world
is either people who
love them or hate them, and I
am very much on team leftovers.
And I was going to do a book
just of reinventing leftovers,
mostly because I fell in love
with a title I came up with,
which was "It's Me Again."
And I thought that
was so clever.
But then I had an issue
because I was like,
do I give you the recipe for
the thing in the first place?
How is that going to work?
So it became a much
bigger and, I think,
much more useful
and meaningful book.
So it's all my favorite
menus in one place, all
the very, very simple
recipes to make those menus.
So you can make a whole meal.
And all the menus
are super personal,
and there's old family
stories and stuff like that.
And then following each
menu are all these ideas
for ways to use your
leftovers in creative ways.
And the whole notion of
that is to really empower
home cooks to love
leftovers as much
as I do, to open your
fridge, and if you
see a container, to
not feel like, oh,
that same thing again.
You can really do
something new with it,
make a whole new
meal that is almost
unrecognizable from the first.
So yeah, that's the book.
I'm super excited about it.
And yeah, as Karen mentioned,
it came out this week
on Beyonce's birthday, which I
feel like is a very good omen.
So I'm super excited
to share it with you.
And I'm going to
show you guys two
of the incredibly simple
recipes, the original and then
the leftover.
And because it's
Friday and TGIF,
we're going to start
with a boozy recipe.
And so the first one--
it's a dessert
recipe for something
I called a boozy lemon slushie.
For anyone who doesn't cook,
this is the perfect recipe.
It's a very, very
festive dessert.
Everyone loves it.
I think it takes
everyone by surprise.
It's a little unexpected.
But you really don't--
you just need to know how to
open a bottle or a container,
and that's it.
So it starts with lemon sorbet,
which I say you should buy.
They made it because
they're amazing.
You do not need to make it.
If you like making lemon
sorbet, by all means.
But I feel like my secret is
I'm actually a really lazy cook,
and I don't like to
do a lot of dishes.
So if you can get a really
great outcome for as little work
and as few dishes as possible,
that is fine with me.
So this is the lemon
sorbet they made.
It's beautiful.
It's super tart and delicious.
And then you
basically-- this could
be a champagne glass or wine
glass or anything like that.
And you just put a little
scoop, and then you top it off.
So Marianne has already
put a little bit of vodka
and a little bit
of sparkling wine.
And then you can serve
it with-- just as is.
You can serve it with
a spoon and a straw,
kind of like a milkshake.
It's beautiful, it's
effervescent, and it's tart.
And it's a little sweet,
and it's not too sweet
because you have
vodka in all that.
And it's such a festive,
fun way to end a meal.
So I'm just going
to scoop these out.
And then if you guys
want to make your Friday
lunch a little more mellow--
yeah, thank you so much.
Thank you.
I think the biggest
secret in the kitchen
is bringing her with you.
And she can prepare everything
ahead, and it makes it so easy.
So then the fun--
so I don't know if you'll have
leftovers from this, per se.
But if you have a
little bit of vodka
in the bottle left, a
little sparkling wine,
a little lemon sorbet--
if you didn't quite scrape
the bottom of the container,
the super fun thing
to do is if you have--
I'm going to move over here.
This is just
store-bought poundcake.
Again, you don't have
to make anything.
You obviously can
make it if you'd like.
But if you slice it, and
then if you put-- well,
we're just going to
do little pieces.
And then this is a little bit--
that mixture I just made, the
lemon sorbet, vodka prosecco--
now it's kind of melted.
It's not as cold and refreshing,
but it's still perfectly good.
So then you just pour
it over your slice,
and you just let that
sit a little bit.
And I feel like I should
have done the other cup.
You just let that soak in, and
it makes this delicious, lemony
poundcake.
And you can serve
that with vanilla ice
cream or whipped cream, creme
fraiche, something like that.
Again, a really, really
lovely dessert, and you're
not wasting that little
bit that might be left.
And interestingly,
"Now and Again"
is totally a book about food
waste without ever overtly
saying so.
But it's really about using
up everything and seeing
the potential in the bottom of
the jar, the leftover, whatever
you might have.
And it's seeing the
potential in all this stuff,
knowing that you
can make something
totally new and great, and
yeah, not wasting stuff.
And I know you guys do
amazing work with that
here, which is incredible.
Because especially on a
large scale at Google,
you really can make
a big difference.
You think about how much
food we all throw out.
And if you times that
by however many people
work here and eat here all
the time, it's enormous.
And my feelings about
food waste and everything
is things need to change
at really large scale,
industrial levels
with companies,
with large-scale
farms and stuff.
But I think I'm also a big
believer that small differences
add up to big changes.
And if we as individuals
reframe the way
we think about everything
we consume, whether it's
food or anything, and
not throwing things out,
really taking the time
to invest in good stuff--
I do believe that
makes a difference.
And I think that's
just a way to reframe
your thinking in general.
I think if you start
looking at your food-- which
is the thing we consume every
day-- in this way, that's,
I guess, a bit more mindful.
For me, at least, it kind of
floats into everything else.
And it's also an
excuse to just keep
eating vodka, which is great.
So yeah, we'll pass
out the drinks.
I should mention, if
anyone has a question
at any point about something I'm
cooking, or the book, or dogs--
I love to talk about
my dogs at any point.
So the next recipe
is a savory one.
It's not a drink or dessert.
And it's actually the
cover of the book.
So we thought it
would be a little fun
to bring the cover to life.
So the story behind it is it's
a radicchio and squash salad,
and then the leftover
is turning it
into a really, really delicious
grilled cheese sandwich.
Basically, any excuse for a
grilled cheese is fine by me.
And the salad comes from
the Thanksgiving menu
in the book, which I named a
"No Stress Thanksgiving," which
you normally don't see those
two terms together, I think.
Has anyone here ever
made a Thanksgiving meal?
Yeah, a few of you.
It can be-- did you
find it daunting?
Was it?
Yeah.
And I think it really
doesn't have to be.
I think so many people
who prepare a big meal,
whether it's Thanksgiving
or any other holiday,
or just a large
group of friends,
there's so much pressure
and a long to-do list.
And I'm a big believer in
taking that pressure away as
much as possible.
You can delegate things.
You can make so
much ahead of time.
You can simplify recipes.
You still have all these
really familiar, great flavors
without having to make every
single component from scratch
or anything like that.
So this salad is such a
great example of, I think,
the book in general,
but also that menu.
Since it's radicchio,
which is so hearty--
it's not like a really
delicate lettuce or anything.
This can really
stand up to anything.
And roasted squash-- you
can make the whole salad.
You can dress it and
everything, and it can just
sit, whether it's on your buffet
table or whatever it might be,
your counter.
You can make it ahead of time.
You can even make it a day
ahead of time and serve it,
and it will be great.
So I love thinking about
stuff like that when you're
entertaining so you're not--
again, you're not stressed.
You're not having to wait
last minute to make a dressing
and toss it
together, and worried
if someone shows up
late, and something
is getting wilted and soggy,
or anything like that.
So that's the idea
for this salad.
And then this radicchio--
which we're in early
September, but by the time
Thanksgiving rolls
around, radicchio squash
are everywhere in the market.
I feel like I'm
seeing a happy face.
Do you guys like the-- yeah.
It's a good--
I feel you could have this for
breakfast because it's fruit.
That would be fun.
But the radicchio is
a little bit bitter,
and then the squash
is really sweet.
So I love that together.
For some people, it's
a little too bitter.
I really like a
little bit of bitter.
I love broccoli rabe
and that kind of stuff.
But if it is a little
too bitter for you,
this could be any kind
of tough, hearty green.
So this could make a beautiful
kale salad, anything like that.
You could use--
escarole would be great.
So the way we prepare it is--
this is perfect.
Sometimes when you
get it, there's
kind of sad leaves
on the outside.
They're a little dry or wilted.
These are beautiful and fresh.
But if you have that,
you just peel them off.
And then with that kind of food
waste stuff in mind, you can--
what I love to do is keep
a Ziploc bag in my freezer.
So when I have onion peels,
or if I'm scraping a carrot,
and you have the peel from
that, or the end of celery,
which is maybe not
something you want to eat,
but there's a lot
of flavor in there--
all those little bits of
vegetable scraps and stuff,
you go into your freezer,
into your plastic bag,
and you just put them there.
And then you don't have
to worry about them.
And they're not going to go
bad or get smelly or anything
like that.
And when that bag is full of
all your vegetable scraps,
you just dump it into a
pot, cover it with water,
and you can make delicious,
wonderful vegetable broth
that you can use
to cook things in.
It's great to cook rice
in, or you can add--
if you buy rotisserie chickens
or you make roast chicken,
you can put those bones
or whatever it might be.
And then it's not like every
single time you're cooking,
you have to go make stock.
But you can keep
your stockpile going.
So that's a great tip.
But we don't have to do that
here because these are perfect.
So just cut it up.
And I like to cut it
to keep the root intact
so it doesn't go everywhere
while you're cutting it,
and then just across.
And that little guy could
go into your container.
And then they have
already roasted
the squash, which makes my
life super easy and is awesome.
So this is butternut squash.
So with that, because
the skin is tough,
you can peel it off with a
vegetable peeler and knife.
You can also buy peeled
squash at the supermarket.
I feel like every supermarket
these days has those done.
I'm all for-- if
that shortcut means
you're going to go home and
make dinner, take the shortcut.
That is totally fine by me, not
that you need my permission.
But I think that's
the hardest part
of preparing squash
is the peeling it,
because that skin is so tough.
If you can find--
which you can, because
I feel like you
guys live in or
near here, and you
live-- you're working near
Chelsea Market and everything.
So in the fall, if
there's delicata squash,
I love the salad with that.
It's the cylindrical one,
and it's got striped skin.
And I love it because the skin
on delicata is super thin,
and you don't have to peel it.
It's totally edible.
It gets really
crispy and delicious.
So again, I'm a little bit lazy,
so that's my preferred squash,
because it's so easy.
Because you don't
have to peel it.
You just scrape out the
seeds like if you were
cutting a melon, basically.
You can also make a salad
with sweet potatoes.
But anyway, whatever you
use-- sweet potatoes, squash,
whatever kind, just
cut it into cubes,
toss it with some olive oil and
salt, and roast it in a 400,
425 oven until--
this is perfect.
It's a little bit brown.
And brown just means sweeter
and crisper and more flavorful.
So don't-- I always find that
whenever I roast vegetables
or anything, it turns out the
best when I forget about them
for a little bit and I
really let them get brown,
because I can be a
little impatient.
So the browner it
is, the more flavor.
And then the
dressing is so easy.
So it's a little bit of mustard.
And this is my go-to dressing
for pretty much everything.
A little-- I think we
did apple cider vinegar.
You can use any vinegar.
I think in general,
use what you have.
I hate if I'm going
to make something,
and someone calls for
something I don't have,
and I feel like I have to
go the grocery store again.
If you have any vinegar,
just use what you have.
Use sherry vinegar.
Use red wine vinegar.
All you're doing is adding acid,
so whatever you have, use that.
and I feel like whatever you
have is probably what you like,
because I would hope
you wouldn't buy it
if you don't like it.
So if you don't like
apple cider vinegar,
but you love white wine
vinegar, and that's
what you, by all means,
use what you enjoy.
So a little bit of that.
And then this is maple syrup,
but this could easily be honey.
You could even use a
pinch of brown sugar.
You're just looking to add
a little bit of sweetness.
I like using honey
or maple syrup mostly
because they're
already in liquid form,
so they dissolve really easily
when you're making dressings.
They also have a
little bit more flavor,
which is really nice,
as opposed to sugar.
And yeah, they're--
sugar is sugar,
but they're a little
bit healthier.
They're a little less processed
than white sugar or something
like that.
So a little bit.
And we're going to season this
with some salt and pepper.
And then my--
I love these little jars.
My favorite way
to mince garlic is
either use a microplane grater
or use the side of your knife.
I'll make a little room
here so you can see.
And I think garlic and
dressings is like--
I feel like anytime you have a
dressing that you really love,
and you're like, what's that
little something, in my mind,
it's usually a little bit of
garlic or shallot or something
from the onion, garlic family.
I think you can really
taste when that's there.
And when it's not there,
it's sort of like something
is missing.
So yeah, I don't like using
a garlic press-- again,
because I hate cleaning them.
I feel like everything
gets stuck in there.
And why take out something
else that you're just
going to use for one thing?
So I've used this for the
squash, or they did it for me.
And I've used it for this.
So why clean something else?
So I just took that little--
you know the root end of it?
I just sliced that off.
And then I just put the
knife like this, like flat,
and give it a little smash.
And then once it's smashed up,
you just put a little salt.
And salt is flavor, so
that's great to add,
but it's also an abrasive.
So it's going to help you--
it basically acts as a little
grinder for your garlic.
So you keep the
knife flat like that,
and then just the heel of
your hand-- you just mash it.
And you mash it into a paste.
And what's great
about this is it's
like you're turning your
knife into a garlic press.
So you're making
this puree of it
so it will dissolve
into your dressing.
Because I love
garlic in dressings,
but I don't want to eat
a whole clove of it.
I feel like that
would be not fun--
or not fun for probably
whoever I'm eating with.
So yeah, so then you just turn
it like that, scrape it up.
And that's that.
So you whisk that in.
So anytime I make
a dressing, I like
to mix basically
everything except the oil
or whatever fat you're using--
I like to mix it all together,
make one emulsified mixture
that can then--
you mix your oil into.
And you can taste
it at this point.
It's going to be really
strong because it doesn't
have the fat cutting it.
But you're tasting
it at this point
for that balance
of sweet to acidic,
and the garlic if you
wanted to add more,
if you need a little
bit more vinegar.
I'm super happy with this.
So this thing-- I press here.
So most salad dressing
recipes, there's
usually a ratio of usually 3--
I'm sorry, 1 part vinegar to 3
parts oil, or even 4 parts oil.
I like really strong, assertive
dressing, so more like 1 part
vinegar to 2 parts oil.
And I think you just
taste more stuff.
So I'm just going to eyeball
it based on what I have.
I'm also going to do my
other favorite trick, which
if you're whisking dressing
or anything, if you
put a little towel under your
bowl, it'll help hold it.
And wait to put that in.
Yeah.
And then-- oh, there we go.
You can do it kind of slowly.
This thing is good
because it keeps you--
like portion control.
I feel like this is like trying
to take a selfie when you press
the button at the same time.
Yeah, that looks pretty good.
Yeah, that's great.
So then you've
got your dressing,
and then you just add the
roasted squash, again,
sweet potato, whatever you
want, all that beautiful, sliced
radicchio.
I'm just going to go a little
light on it since the bowl is
kind of small.
And then I wash my
hands just before.
I think your hands are the most
useful tool in the kitchen.
And clean hands-- just don't
be afraid to get in there.
And I think the more you
interact with your food
and touch it and all
that kind of stuff,
the more you'll develop
those intuitive senses of how
dressed your salad should
be, when your chicken is
done, when your fish is done.
So I think-- just don't
be afraid to touch it.
And it's also good because
it means you can really coat
everything with the dressing.
And then-- yeah.
Use a bigger bowl so
you don't spill it all.
But yeah, that's it.
And that's the salad you
guys are all enjoying.
And what's awesome is that--
yeah, that can just sit,
and it's good the next
day, or you can make it
a few hours ahead of time.
And that dressing you
can put on anything.
It's amazing also
just as its own sauce.
If you-- I feel like I'm
always using roasted chicken
or grilled fish as an example,
but a vinaigrette doesn't just
have to belong on a salad.
You can spoon that on
top of grilled steak
or whatever you want.
It'll just add that nice,
garlicy, acidic thing.
Yeah.
You can do a different
green, different squash,
but super versatile.
And also nice for holiday
meals to have something really
healthy and fresh, because I
think sometimes we get a little
weighed down with all the
really delicious stuffing
mashed potatoes, which
I have no problem with.
But it's nice to cut it with
something acidic and crunchy.
And then if you have
leftover salad--
everyone has had their
meal, they've enjoyed it,
but there's still some at
the bottom of the bowl.
Don't throw it out.
I feel like salad is one
of the things people just
get rid of immediately.
Because you feel
like, what are you
going to do with leftover salad?
This one-- again,
because it is so hearty,
will really stay in good shape.
And my favorite thing
to do is to turn it
into a grilled cheese.
But a few ideas for other--
if you have just dressed greens,
like bib lettuce or something
like that, that's going to
get really wilted and soggy.
My recommendation for
that is to lean into it.
Don't try to fight that texture.
And there's an idea in the book.
There's a menu, actually,
for a bib lettuce salad.
It has a really delicious
shallot vinaigrette,
and I serve it as part of a
meal with mashed cauliflower
that's sort of like
mashed potatoes,
but much lower in
carbohydrates and stuff,
which normally I wouldn't
necessarily suggest.
But A, it's delicious,
and B, my wife Grace
lives with type 1 diabetes.
We were talking
about it earlier.
And it's made a lot of really
healthy changes in our homes.
But that cauliflower
and the salad--
if you have leftovers
the next day,
I suggest turning
that into a soup.
And then you just put your
leftover wilted greens
in with it, and you puree it,
and that wilted lettuce will
just wilt into oblivion.
But that vinaigrette and
the body from the lettuce
and everything-- it's going
to be such a beautiful part
of a really silky,
delicious cauliflower soup,
and it will season it.
So there is really new life
for anything and everything.
So grilled cheese--
I don't think
anyone really needs
a recipe for a grilled cheese.
But my big tip for
it is to really not
be afraid of mayonnaise.
And I put a little bit on
both sides of the bread.
And that means the inside
of your grilled cheese
is going to have
some good moisture,
like mayonnaise on any sandwich.
But it also means that
the outside of the bread--
I'm not going to put
any butter in the pan.
And mayonnaise is mostly oil.
It's oil in a solid form.
It's held together with an
egg yolk or whatever Hellman's
uses.
I have no idea.
So when you spread
it on the outside,
it means that every
single bit of this bread
is going to hit the
pan, and that oil
is going to make contact.
And when fat and
heat come together
on something dry like
bread or chicken skin,
or if you're roasting
it or something,
that's when you get really
nice, brown, delicious--
like a crust on something,
like butter in pie
dough and stuff like that.
So yeah, a little
mayonnaise on the outside,
a little on the inside.
I feel like if you're going
to have a grilled cheese,
you should really go for it.
Really just use your
mayo and your cheese.
And then this is cheddar,
but it can be whatever cheese
you have.
Swiss cheese or
Gruyere is great.
It doesn't matter.
And then I put a
little layer of that,
and then the leftover
salad, a little handful.
And it just adds a little--
not only is it a good way
to use that leftover salad,
but it also adds a
nice, wonderful layer
to your grilled cheese, a
little bit more substantial.
I feel like it's a
vegetable, so then you
can feel really guiltless about
eating your grilled cheese.
And I'm just going to turn this
down a little because it's hot.
A little cheese
on top, and then--
yeah, mayo here for the inside.
I just give it a little press,
put all that stuff together.
That also guarantees that the
bottom of the grilled cheese
is really pressing down
onto that hot surface
and will get super,
super crispy.
Yeah.
When you guys were
doing them before,
that smell of toasted bread--
bread toasting and any kind
of fat, I think, is like--
you need to sell your house or
something, make a few of these.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What
cheese are you using?
JULIA TURSHEN: Cheddar, yeah.
But it could be anything.
And you can use a mixture, too,
if you have a few little bits
of cheese lying around.
If you just grate them
all and mix them together,
that's a great way to use up--
if you've had a party,
and you've served cheese
with wine or whatever, and
you're left with little ends,
and it's like, what am
I going to do with this,
and you're not going to put them
out again, cut off the rind.
Grate them all.
Mix them together.
I think that's the best thing.
And then--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JULIA TURSHEN: Sorry?
JULIA TURSHEN: That's
a good question.
I have never done that.
I feel like I wouldn't
recommend that.
I feel like it's going
to get a little cloudy.
That's a good question, though.
Yeah.
That's one thing I don't have
an idea for, the cheese rind.
Some things you just let go.
Yeah.
So just let that get brown.
I'm going to flip it over
because I bet it's brown.
And that little piece--
sometimes I will purposely
sprinkle extra cheese on the
pan because that little bit that
comes off that's crispy and
delicious is the best part.
So you can do that on purpose
and just make extra of that.
Yeah, that's perfect.
Yeah.
And that is the grilled cheese.
I'm just going to let
the other side get brown.
But yeah, I've
successfully made a mess.
But you've seen two of
the recipes that are so
simple-- the salad,
the lemon sorbet,
the boozy slushy that can turn
into the lemony poundcake.
And you can make things.
You can make them
more than once.
It can be a whole other thing.
And I should mention
also, a big part
of the inspiration for the
book is because Grace, my wife,
and I live in a
really rural area.
We're just two
hours north of here.
But it's-- it feels
very far away.
And I grew up a block
from here, and I grew up
with lots of takeout, lots
of-- a million restaurants
in a five-minute vicinity.
And now I live in an area
where there's no takeout
and you have to go pretty
far to go to a restaurant.
But yes, it's beautiful.
No, I'm super happy.
But it means we eat
every meal at home,
so we're always cooking.
And I don't necessarily
want to start from scratch
every single day.
So I will always--
I will make this, or
even more than this,
just for the two of us,
because I know that I'm
going to keep using it.
And in addition to
the grilled cheese,
this can also be part of
a grain bowl or something
like that the next day.
This with some shredded
roast chicken tossed into it
is delicious, or a
piece of grilled salmon,
or something like that.
So I just love the idea
that the food you make,
you can make it once, and
it can keep serving you.
And you can put in that
effort at one point.
And it doesn't have to be a ton
of effort, as you have seen,
but then you can keep
reaping the benefits of it.
So that's the "again"
of "Now & Again."
And I should probably
pull this off.
Does anyone have any questions?
How are you doing?
AUDIENCE: Great.
JULIA TURSHEN: Good.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
JULIA TURSHEN: Oh, that's OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What might you use
instead of radicchio if you
don't have that lying around?
Yeah
JULIA TURSHEN: I think
kale is awesome in here.
And I like when--
I think you were talking about
you did a kale salad yesterday.
I'd be curious what
his technique is.
But I like to chop
up kale, any kind,
like the curly one
or the dinosaur kale,
whatever you have.
Chop it up kind of like this.
And then I put a little--
either lemon juice or vinegar,
and a little bit of
salt. And you have
to give it a little massage.
So you really work it with
your hands and break it down.
Because I think
sometimes, kale salads,
you feel a little
bit like a dinosaur
eating it or something.
It's so leafy and stuff.
So when you do that
stuff to break it down--
that's the only
difference I would
do if I did this with
kale is to give it that--
break it down with a little
something acidic-- lemon,
vinegar, salt. And then
just the same dressings,
same sweet potatoes
or squash, whatever.
You can also-- this is
delicious with arugula.
A box of washed baby
arugula is great.
It won't last in the
same way because it
will get a little
bit more wilty,
but that would be delicious
tucked into a grilled cheese,
either of those.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JULIA TURSHEN: Does
it have sorbet?
That's OK.
It's like if you had leftovers.
There's some-- you
want some here?
Yeah, come.
The only problem
with the boozy--
yeah, the problem with the boozy
slushies is if you have one,
and then you go to
make the poundcake,
you'll probably
forget something.
You keep eating.
Yeah.
There's no wrong at all.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Besides vodka,
what kind of other alcohol
would you recommend?
JULIA TURSHEN: Yeah.
So instead of vodka, would I
recommend any other alcohol?
You can do this just
with a sparkling wine.
That would be fine
if you wanted to make
it a little less boozy boozy.
And you can mix
it up in any way.
I feel like if you
did-- you can really
get creative and have fun.
An orange sorbet
with a little bit
of Campari and a sparkling wine
would be delicious, kind of
like a spritz, basically.
You can really mix it up.
I haven't tried anything in the
bourbon category or anything
like that.
I did-- actually, in
"Small Victories,"
there's a really
delicious milkshake that
has peaches and bourbon in it.
So I think I have brown
liquor and a more ice
cream, milkshake direction.
But yeah, the clear stuff for--
rum would be delicious.
A clear-- a white
rum would be awesome.
So yeah.
Now I'm thinking of more ideas.
Use what you have.
But yeah, you can
be really flexible.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JULIA TURSHEN: Or a lime sorbet
with tequila would be awesome.
Invite me over for that.
AUDIENCE: I just love that
this is a food waste book,
but it's not in your face, and
it seems really approachable.
So [INAUDIBLE].
JULIA TURSHEN: Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
It wasn't the-- that wasn't
even the original idea.
And then as I was
working on it, I
was like, oh, this is the
message here that I didn't
even quite realize,
which I think sometimes
is a nice way to--
it's a really serious issue.
And I think sometimes,
if you approach it
in a way that's
fun, it's a nice way
to approach lots of tough stuff.
So yeah, thank you.
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Is there anything
that you have found that--
when you have made dinner,
or any kind of a meal,
that you should
not use it again?
JULIA TURSHEN: That's
a good question.
Some things-- I would say the
only thing I can think of is
if you're doing any--
which there's not a
recipe in the book,
but if doing any kind
of raw fish thing--
if you're making your own
sushi or ceviche or something,
I feel like leaving that
in the fridge for a week
and then making something
might be a little questionable.
But one question that's
come up a few times
in talking about the book is--
I think a lot of people
look at leftovers,
and you think the food
is not good anymore.
It's not fresh.
You can probably speak
more to this than I can in.
In restaurant kitchens
and everything,
you make so much ahead of time.
Not everything is
made just that minute.
And so much of cooking
is about planning ahead.
And with that comes the
knowledge that food lasts.
You can make something
and put it in the fridge,
and it's going to be OK.
You can hold onto
it for a few days.
You can hold onto most
stuff for, like, a week.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there an
ingredient in the book
that you find is most occurring
or the more recurring that's
never out of your pantry?
JULIA TURSHEN: That's
a great question.
AUDIENCE: What's one thing
that you don't run out of
or that comes up in
the book most often?
JULIA TURSHEN: That's
a great question.
This is probably really
obvious, but I am never
out of olive oil.
There is not just the
bottle on my counter.
There's two in the drawer.
Because to me, the idea of
running out of olive oil
is like, well,
then what do I do?
I can run out of anything
else and figure it out.
That's fine.
But with that, I would be lost.
So olive oil and salt--
it sounds really basic,
but I really think
with those two things,
you can make anything.
AUDIENCE: Just for fun,
what's your go-to meal?
JULIA TURSHEN: Lately,
what is my go-to meal?
Well, so much of this book comes
from that I don't love eating
the same thing over and over.
It's like the reinvention thing.
But I would say in
general, I've been--
because it's end of summer where
we all live, in New York state
or nearby, the tomatoes
and peppers and everything
are so delicious right now.
So I do a lot of chop, Greek-ish
salads, so all different kinds
of tomatoes, chopped
cucumbers, peppers,
and then big pieces of good
feta cheese and vinegar and oil
and dried oregano.
I love that.
And that with-- sometimes
we'll grill sausages
or chicken or something.
And to me, that's
a perfect meal.
AUDIENCE: Sounds good to me.
JULIA TURSHEN: Yeah.
And then leftovers of that--
you can-- maybe
take out the feta.
Take out your little cubes.
But then you can make
delicious gazpacho.
Or you can just eat the salad
the next day, That's fine.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: What's next?
JULIA TURSHEN: What is next?
I'm about to start
working on a book
with a friend of mine that
is not like my recipes.
We're doing recipes from--
I probably shouldn't-- I should
ask her how much I can say.
It's going to be
recipes from grandmas,
which I'm really excited about.
So maybe we can come
back here in maybe--
probably two years
with some grandmas.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
JULIA TURSHEN: Not my grandma
because she doesn't cook.
I gave her "Now & Again,"
and she's like, that's nice.
PRESENTER: Great.
Thank you.
JULIA TURSHEN: Thank
you guys so much.
PRESENTER: Thanks to Julia.
JULIA TURSHEN: OK.
[APPLAUSE]